just sleeping around different for men
and for women I don't know I think
whatever people want to do like if
they're sleep if they're if like a
woman's like body count like is higher
than like our guys like it shouldn't
matter it matters to a lot of guys
though yeah for some reason it doesn't
compete in my brain as to why it does
but they do view it differently no it
just held to another standard where they
can sleep with literally anyone and the
minute a woman does it's like oh you're
a slag or like there's like the massive
discourse where it's like your vagina
gets massive which is a complete lie
because you push a baby out and then it
stretches back so it's like if you push
a baby out on your vagina can stretch
back then why does it matter how many
people you sleep with like that doesn't
change it do you know what I mean but as
a man they can just go with whoever and
it's like oh you're a lad like that's
sick no 100 I testified to that and I
feel like a lot of like strictly in like
the straight Community they and like the
patriarchal ideals are very much like
keep this old like Victorian like
ideology where a woman has to be like
virginal to be like attractive I agree
with them no you don't think so no what
about you society says yes no no I don't
think so so if you were talking to a guy
is there a body count that would be too
high for you to talk to like if you said
I've slept with a thousand women yeah no
it's a no for me yeah it's a no a
thousand women to be honest you know
like how um men are swimming like how
many people have you slept with that
never comes into our question yeah it's
never a thing because it's like that's
your past that's whatever it is it
doesn't really matter no I think it's uh
you feel it different though no no debut
definitely oh right now I don't think I
review it differently if I had the same
body count between a man and a woman I
think it would be like I wouldn't think
anything of it I didn't think no no I
wouldn't say I sleep around a lot I'd be
like as long as you're clean from STDs
can I I I do view it differently but
I'll tell you why I'll tell you why I'll
tell you why I'll tell you why because I
think like women have to in general and
I know there's exceptions but by and
large like have to be more attached and
like like a guy more and it's like easy
for a woman to get sex for guys they
have to earn it like a guy a guy has to
be a certain height for you to be
attracted to him he has to be a certain
level of income certain level of like
everybody
not not really if you look at the data
you don't percent of the time women
swipe right on dating apps
oh God yeah like women swipe right five
to ten percent of the time where men
swipe right 50 men are like you see hot
in there yeah is she hot there and
willing just like okay you guys are
pretty girls right you go out and you
ask ask 10 guys if they want to have sex
you'll get to take her
but him it's not gonna be the same if he
goes up to 10 10 girls and says do you
want to have sex with me they're going
to look at him like he's nuts or the
guys will be like when and where but men
are probably more likely to do that
though like go up to someone and be like
hey I don't know yeah I feel like you
have a point with that what's the point
what's the boy
girls a bit more than goes off
and I guess that kind of proves your
point like it's like harder for them to
get like do you do one out of three men
is either a virgin or hasn't had sex in
the past year I really yeah no way I
actually whoa I want to say I refuse to
believe because it's like maybe I
shouldn't I shouldn't be jumping to
conclusions do you think body count
doesn't matter cool snow what's your
body count I don't count not that I'm
saying it's a lot roughly cows under 20.
yeah okay you're more honest than me
everyone tells me virgin no no because
for me it's not like a show-off thing
that I'll say oh yeah like it's
something to show off about it's just
like a
you know guys mostly amongst men like oh
yeah I've stuck with this many but with
women it's not that much I think it's
more emotional than physical
so I would never answer that like even
if God was standing in front of me
even if God was standing in front of me
the only
one just say
I don't really care what your body
counts are
well everyone today I asked for contacts
because then like where is that gonna go
if I'd like to randomly save my body
count like you can go anywhere I have
some [ __ ] to say but we can talk about
it after this is happening
it's just interesting you know what I
mean like it's like if it really didn't
matter why don't we all just tell each
other yeah and we do you'll be surprised
would you say that because it's more
emotional for us that sleeping around is
different because we have to have an
emotional connection where men will just
screw anything I mean I don't I can't
speak for all men just like in general
right for myself like yeah I think it's
more like emotional rather than just
physical yeah if I connect with you then
I connect with you well I think that's
why I think that's why like men say it's
different is because like we have to
like be attacked we have to like him in
some way where a dude can screw a girl
he hates that's it we need to have some
type of physical or some kind of
emotional we need to connect in some way
so you kind of understand where they're
coming from a little bit they're pretty
reasonable I don't know if I understand
but I I don't know I can't really answer
that okay do you think body count
matters yeah yeah
yes it does yeah why do you think so
many people say it doesn't because
they're Liars
for capping would you say your body
count
I I don't know no no no no
the only reason I ask usually people
will say it doesn't matter and then I'll
ask like what's your body count because
they say it doesn't matter see we're not
Liars yeah at least you guys are honest
I don't know if I believe the Virgin
thing no I swear I would not mind it
would it wouldn't affect me at all if
it's the one if he's the one do you guys
believe in the one yeah
like a Disney like I feel like there's
just like choices and trade-offs and you
get to like like no one's there's not
one there's not one person that's like
the one I think there is
so if you're watching
we'll find it hey come here real quick
they're fake come on
[Music]
oh yeah um
the question today is is sleeping around
different for men and for women oh
definitely because men hold no emotional
attachment women kind of like will hold
an emotional attachment if that makes
sense so he he says he says it matters
he says it's different what do you
saying how's it different women hold
more emotional attachment like generally
if you if you want to [ __ ] with a guy
you wouldn't go in it to be like oh yeah
I'm just having sex you want to want him
to know you all of that [ __ ] compared to
like I'm just being serious
generalize is different for everyone
that I don't ever like want to deal with
that [ __ ] but then majority of girls
would have feelings towards the guy
you're not going to pick up some random
guy that looks like a four over five out
of ten and just be like yeah yeah and
I'll allow him to smash I think the
question was sorry I'm like taking your
spot as an interviewer the question was
how do you see it differently between
the men have no like if a guy wants to
mess with a girl he has no emotional
attachment you do
I generally see most men have no
emotional attachment when it comes to
sex okay if you if beer you wanted to
get sex all you have to do is go around
and say anyone want to have sex we'd
have people lined up if you if he did
this right now he's he's a good look
he's a good looking guy if he went he
went around and did that I'm saying I'm
saying I'm saying look it look it look
I'm just I'm being real like if he goes
around asking girls for sex they're
gonna be like no get the [ __ ] away from
me but me and you me and you all we have
to do is ask yeah
yeah I personally don't see it different
if a girl told me she has a thousand
bodies so people like a guy that looks
like me
should hold like the same standards
that's what you mean yes but like in
reality it's not the same in this yeah
like in reality it's not but the
question was what do I think and I
wouldn't think of a woman less than I do
a man if they have the same body count
is what I was saying you're supposed to
say this if it's an average looking guy
do you think he would have as much
success to what God has way more good
looking in a general sense than Force to
get a woman or if he's trying to get her
in bed or relationship status whatever
it is do you think that will happen no
but I think it's the same way with women
an average looking girl and an average
girl would have a better chance with any
type of guy she would want yeah I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna put this in
perspective I I consider myself average
I literally do I bet no no I know girls
will always correct me but like I'm just
being real like I feel like most people
are normal looking and I feel like I'm
normal looking and I've had I'm an NBA
player sliding my DMs
it's not a flex they're looking it's not
it's not look at like we're not gonna
look at like we're not gonna I'm saying
I'm saying like the set of flex though
they're just looking for easy sex and so
I'm saying like that would never happen
like to a guy or like a blue check mark
girl is gonna slide in his DMS of just a
normal guy